[Música]
tengo una familia numerosa y fanática
del deporte numerosa somos siete
hermanos cinco varones cuatro de los
cuales somos a ellos uno atrás del otro
así que como pueden imaginar en mi casa
siempre había gente suficiente
compararme en algunos equipos y jugar
algo siempre nos lo pasábamos
compitiendo entre hermanos y amigos
y algún partidito de ping pong algún
partido de basket de fútbol jugamos
mucho al fútbol porque también somos
futboleros nos encanta el fútbol y somos
fanáticos de belgrano el pirata cordobés
recuerdo como si fuera a hacer cuando mi
viejo nos llegaba a la cancha y volvía a
mi casa absolutamente fascinado con
con lo que generaba ese grupo de
jugadores adentro de cancha en tanta
gente tanta gente que se volvía tan loca
por lo que pasa dentro de cancha como
sentían los goles en contra como lo
sufrían las derrotas como disfrutábamos
porque esto también era parte de eso
como disfrutábamos de los goles de las
victorias en una pasión tan grande y
deseaba con todo mi alma ser uno de esos
protagonista en algún momento
los soñar tanto que muchas veces me vea
y en mis propios y mis propios sueños a
mí sentado en la tribuna con mi viejo mi
hermano viendo el partido y que de
repente se lesionaba la figura del
equipo y el técnico no tenía mejor idea
que mirar para la tribuna apuntarme a mí
y mandarme a la cancha a jugar
soy un salto está dentro de la cancha me
ponía los botines la ropita del club
todo numerito todo increíble entraba a
la cancha y jugó el mejor partido en mi
vida era figura así un gol en la última
jugada de ganamos gracias a mí me
convertí en ídolo total del equipo y en
mi mejor momento del sueño cuando estaba
pasando por el mejor momento de todos
punto se termina el sueño mi mamá me
despertaba para ir al colegio
y porque les cuento mi sueño porque hoy
parado en este lugar miro para atrás y
me dio a mí mismo loco ese sueño que
tuviste ese ese sueño ideal que tuviste
de chico de alguna manera lo logres de
cumplir porque si bien no fui jugador de
fútbol
y dolor en el grano y metí ese gol que
viví en ese momento del sueño
si pude experimentar lo que es jugar en
estadios explotado de gente y pues
sentir esa adrenalina que me corrió por
la sangre cada vez que me tocaba entrar
a la cancha hacer algo para generar algo
en toda la gente que no sabido ver
algo que nunca me hubiese imaginado
cuando era chico realmente nunca me
hubiese imaginado que podía llegar a ese
lugar
y me pregunto cómo se ve
digo
suerte si puedo haber tenido algo de
suerte magia les aseguro que no el
destino así lo quiso
no lo creo tomé muchas decisiones en el
camino
pareciera donde sé
en realidad no tengo la receta exacta de
cómo hice para llegar con mi sueño pero
sí les aseguro que no salte de un día
para el otro que trigo en el cancha que
según mucho trabajo y mucho sacrificio y
creo que en esto fue muy importante ser
una persona responsable y comprometido
como el sol cada vez que que tengo un
compromiso con alguien ya sea conmigo
mismo o con un grupo de personas doy
todo de mí para poder lograrlo
y además tengo lo que llamamos mi red de
valores y les damos red porque está
compuesto por la responsabilidad la e de
esfuerzo y de dedicación
esas tres palabras me fueron acompañando
durante todo esto de toda mi carrera
para ir de a poco logrando cumplir mi
sueño
en realidad digo mi sueño porque me
refiero a ese sueño ideal que tenía el
chico
pero
sinceramente para mí no no fue un sueño
y mirar siempre esforzarte porque va a
ser tal lugar no lo mío fue
el famoso paso a paso
y de ir disfrutando cada cada momento
que iba viviendo
me toca
cumplir una meta chiquita y una que
cumpliese en el estadio con las
siguientes y así por el siguiente por el
siguiente sin imaginarme lo que puede
ser pasar el día de mañana simplemente
viviendo el día a día y disfrutando
mucho lo que mediante lo que me tocaba
hacer así fue cómo pasé de juveniles de
primera división primero y gran sueño
por fue en el primero de mi club después
pasé a ser campeón con la piedra de mi
club quiero otro gran sueño que tenía de
ser cambio volviera el club a un
seleccionador provincial y a ganar
campeonatos con eso también y así era
ese paso a paso
día a día disfrutando
hasta que llegó
el llamado para jugar en los pumas seven
sinceramente en ese momento no tenía
mucha idea de qué se trataba había visto
algo por internet porque no tenía mucha
difusión en ese momento tampoco
pero bueno
me interesó el desafío me gustó ya se
fue efe londres
a jugar el circuito mundial de seven con
selección argentina desde el día que me
puse esa camiseta
esa sensación de orgullo tan grande de
representar a mi país fue que dije a
construir más y con eso vinieron un
montón de otros objetivos un montón de
otros sueños pequeñas metas para ir
cumpliendo en ese paso paso que seguía
haciendo
primero que nada eran pasos cortitos era
estuve en este convocatorias quiero
estar la próxima tengo que hacer lo
mejor de mí para estar en la próxima y
así pasa de torneo torneo de
convocatoria convocatoria así fue que
deseo ser parte del equipo en un mundial
del mundial surgió lo posible por un
foro panamericano y siempre en el paso
paso cumpliendo cada uno de los
objetivos hasta que enseñar los juegos
olímpicos de rio-2016 y ahí estaba solo
como capitán del equipo capitán del
seleccionado argentino de seven que
representaba el país en un juego
olímpico
si me lo hubiese planteado cuando empecé
mi carrera
pero fue simplemente disfrutando de cada
momento que me tocaba vivir y una vez
que sé que cumplir ese sueño jugaron
olimpiada
esta mundial panamericano limpiada un
montón de cosas fueron pasando
y
en el momento tal vez retirarme
pero algo en mi interior me decía no
loco para para siesta disfrute haces lo
que lo que amas está disfrutando esto
ahí tener energía todavía tienes nafta
para seguir avanzando así que
simplemente dije bueno vamos por más del
juego olímpico hoy pasaron tres años y
sigo todavía remando ahora en el equipo
que me cuesta más porque ya soy el viejo
por pero por afano del equipo pero sigo
sigo meses un poco más de esfuerzo tal
es pero sigo disfrutando del día a día y
cumpliendo cada uno de los pequeños
objetivos que muy poniendo
hasta ahora
mencioné mucho de palabra disfrutar
quien disfrute mucho de todo lo que fui
viviendo no les conté la parte oscura
del cuento que es la parte donde tuve
que pasar por muchos malos momentos por
muchos momentos de dudas por muchos por
muchas derrotas muy difíciles que me
costó superar
y me parece que en todo lo que hacemos
siempre toca pasar por momentos
difíciles para después y poder disfrutar
de los logros ya me pasó tuve lesiones
complicadas
me acuerdo estuve hace unos años en mi
se me partió la mandíbula en tres en
dubai lejos de mi familia de mi amigo de
mi gente estaba internado con la cara
así como una sandía
y me imaginaba solo y yo qué hago acá
hasta cuando hubiese ir
rompiendo en el cuerpo por esto seguro
de dejar como que siempre se parecen
esas sensaciones hasta acá llegué pero
de nuevo me o sea existe diciendo para
aguantar aguante que todavía quedan
momentos para disfrutar
también muchas veces dude de mí
la gente por ahí me hace dudar de mí y
de si está bien lo que estoy haciendo si
está bien postergar tantas cosas de mi
vida por esto que tanto disfruto que
tanto deseo y que también me hace hacer
él se está dedicando
años de tu vida a un deporte y después
como dije jugar que va a hacer y la duda
que te genera y a veces me pasa que
hasta me dio asustar con eso y es bueno
a lo mejor el momento de dar un paso del
conector pero de nuevo algo me dice para
disfrutar mucho a más mucho lo que estás
haciendo insistí seguí la parte más
difícil del
de la oscuridad el cuento
en la parte de los fracasos
tuve muchos
y ante los fracasos es que mi sentido de
responsabilidad mejora en contra porque
es cuando cometo un mínimo error oa ese
no tan mínimo y me siento responsable
eso o culpable por las derrotas y la
siento y a veces me persiguen durante
mucho tiempo
uno de los fantasmas que toda emea
vuelta es el de rio-2016 en el juego
olímpico
tuve la oportunidad de hacer jugar al
equipo con una medalla olímpica
en el primer juego olímpico en el cual
el rayo incluido y la desperdicia
r el penal terminado perdiendo el
partido
y secado en nuestro sueño de danone me
dejan
no se imaginan la cantidad de veces que
esa noche
quise renunciar me quisieron mi casa me
quería ir
me sentí una basura sentía que culpa mía
el esfuerzo que hayamos hecho durante un
montón de tiempo adiós al tacho
pero luego este sentido responsabilidad
me obligó el día siguiente a salir a
terminar el torneo de la mejor manera
posible con el equipo poner a cara
este fantasma que les cuento se me
parecen muchas veces en muchos momentos
y me vuelve a decir hasta cuándo razón
hasta cuándo cuándo va a salir pero de
nuevo la vocecita que me dice insistir y
persistir resistir
porque quiero que el que resiste gana a
la larga los resultados cuando hacemos
algo con amor con pasión con dedicación
los resultados llegan
de cualquier manera no simplemente
tenemos que levantar una copa para para
ser revisado muchas veces con pequeñas
cosas nos sentimos realizados
personalmente cada uno y satisfecho con
el lograba lo que nos propusimos
y porque les cuento todo esto estoy
lejos
de crear un ejemplo de vida de
perseverancia de compromiso de
responsabilidad de optimismo
el punto no está ahí simplemente es
comparto mi charla y mi idea y mi
historia que también me sirve a mí mismo
para decirme este el camino que recorre
este parecer esto no está soy
y este el camino que quiero elegir
para que sea cuál es el destino que me
toque ahora más porque mi vida me cargué
por ti estén en su recta final no sé qué
va que va a ser mi vida el día de mañana
pero si sigo por este camino
y voy con mi red con mi red de valores
estoy seguro que nada puede fallar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]